[Music]
one of my name is Brendan Lim I'm the
product manager on cloud functions for
firebase hi I'm Thomas Bolton I'm the
tech lead on cloud functions for
firebase alright so let's get things
started
so I'd like to kick things off by
telling a quick story about our friend
here name's Frank
so everyone say hello to Frank so Frank
is a mobile developer and he wants to
build a brand new mobile app he's tried
many different messaging apps but he
hasn't quite found one that works really
well for him and his friends so he wants
to fix that so after spending countless
hours think of many different product
names he finally settled on one hipster
chat so Frank is determined to make hits
to chat the best messaging apps for
hipsters now Frank really wants to build
a job using Google cloud platform it
just so happens that Frank remembers
that Google is actually quite great in
messaging apps so they must have
detected supporters needs while looking
into Google cloud platform
Frank discovers firebase Google clouds
mobile platform so he starts digging
more into what firebase has to offer and
he gets really excited after he learns
about all the firebase with great
products more specifically Frank's
interested in using firebase is back-end
products to help them build a job
quickly and easily you can use firebase
authentication to manage all those users
you can use the real time database to
store and retrieve chat messages he can
also use cloud storage to store all
those images that are going to be
uploaded by his friends so this will say
Frank a bunch of time and since you can
use these products right away he doesn't
have to worry about setting up his own
servers or or building out all these
features from scratch on his own so
there was a problem though this might
not be as easy as he originally thought
so Frank mapped out a few great core
features that he really wanted to add to
hit Search app many of these common use
cases are found across many different
mobile apps
for instance you want to send
notifications when messages are posted
to a particular chatroom if you want to
resize images after they've been
uploaded to cloud storage he also wants
to filter offensive language that's
written to the database the Frank also
wants use data from firebase analytics
to somehow incentivize his most engaged
users so now Frank's a little concerned
because these are all extremely
important features to him and he's
worried because this is becoming much
more complicated than he originally
thought so let's take one of those use
cases resizing images so sure resizing
images is actually quite quite simple
from you know when you're trying to
create your own custom back end but the
issue here is if he put the back in
between his app and firebase Frank loses
out in some of the best features that
firebase actually has to offer so
Frank's custom back end will be able to
handle some Lil creation no problem the
hole has three implementing any of the
features that he would have gotten for
free if you were used in the firebase
SDKs and communicating directly with
cloud storage one collapse we implement
resumable uploads as well as resumable
downloads he won't get tight integration
with firebase auth to help with end user
authentication we'll discuss them back
end he may end up having to pay for
resources that he's not actually
utilizing now Franklin may also has
worried about building and scaling a
custom backing from scratch to meet the
demands of his app which is surely going
to be a top 10 F so well starting today
Frank can add to do all this require
grades so he can do this without the
added complexity of setting up servers
and creating his own custom back-end
best of all he can still do all these
things very quickly and very easily
so today we launched cloud functions for
firebase in a public beta we've been
working very closely with the cloud
platform team on this for quite some
time
cloud functions for firebase provides
the first-class experience for
five-eights developers built directly on
top of Google cloud function so this
actually has been B number one most
applies
feature from firebase developers and
we're very excited to talk to you about
it today
so cloud functions for firebase is our
programmatic loop it lets you extend and
connect firebase and cloud products to
create a completely serverless mobile
backend for your out cloud functions our
event-driven lightweight JavaScript
functions that are deployed to Google's
cloud which are executed in a managed
node.js environment the cloud functions
for private's provides firebase
developers with a dedicated SDK tight
integration with firebase tooling as
well as additional firebase specific
event providers so how does it work so
as I mentioned earlier cloud functions
are event-driven you specify the event
your function should be triggered by so
first an event is emitted from an event
provider which I'll go over in a little
bit if these conditions are met your
function will be triggered and a new
instance will be spun up then the code
within your function will be executed
now within this code you can make calls
to other services and a pis and as a
result you can choose to invoke other
functions since some of these service
services may actually emit events as
well so that's your code is finished
executing your function will spin down
and you only pay for you use the cloud
function so let's quickly jump back to
Frank's app and see how he can actually
resize images now that he has cloud
function first you'll notice that he no
longer it has to do with setting up his
own servers in the custom back-end his
app can now communicate directly to
cloud storage using the firebase SDK so
this will give him all the added
benefits that we talked about earlier so
now Frank can create a cloud function to
resize images they'll be triggered when
any image is uploaded to cloud storage
at a specific bucket so he won't need to
setup and manage his own servers he
won't need to worry about manually
scaling his servers to meet the demands
of history chat and Frank can have a
completely serverless back-end for his
mobile apps using cloud functions and he
can still do everything that he wants
quickly and easily
and then makes Mike really happy
so cloud functions for firebase has
support from many different event
providers from firebase as well as cloud
these integrations allow you to extend
their functionality through cloud
function so for instance real time
database like you triggered function
when a write occurs at a particular path
in the database the firebase
authentication integration lets you
trigger a function whenever a new user
is created or whenever any users
deleting this fire based analytics
integration lets you trigger a function
whenever a new conversion event is lawed
cloud storage for firebase lets you
trigger a function when the storage
object changes within a bucket cloud
pub/sub let you trigger a function when
a new message is received from a
particular pub subtopic HTTP functions
allow you to expose the unique secure
URL that can be triggered whenever a
request is made so now I'm going to hand
it off at Thomas so he can start seeing
cloud functions in action thanks Brendan
so every demo start with hello world and
this is ours I really love how simple
we've been able to make this with just a
few lines of code we've made a complete
serverless back-end there is no
configuration no rules for scaling up or
down it just works and because cloud
functions is on the latest long-term
stable release of node it was six nine
one right we can use features of
JavaScript six it's a vanilla node
environment that's automatically managed
for you and cloud functions is designed
to help give your service
the last-mile customization that you
need and we price it that way as well
you only have to pay for one hundred
millisecond increments of your code but
we really love this demo it's so simple
we had to add a space filler and add a
new graphic showing you that it works
but
screenshots aren't as fun so let's
actually go into production can we
switch to the laptop so cloud functions
integrates with the firebase
command-line tools and it's as easy to
use as ever all you need to do is type
firebase deploy this is because our SDK
and our CLI work seamlessly together we
can load your code and understand which
cloud functions are in your app once we
finish deploying that code any HTTP
functions URL will be printed here we
can click and that time cloud functions
is able to find or create an available
instance spin up your code and serve the
request so now we can jump to the
firebase console and check out all of
our cloud functions with a bird's-eye
view this console lets us see how many
functions have been deployed what will
trigger those functions how many times
have inspired and how quickly they're
running we can also look at the logs and
you'll see that there's a log statement
every time a function is executed as
well as when it completes if your
function exit because an unhandled
exception or rejected promise it'll be
here as well as with our integration in
stackdriver error reporting if you want
to debug what's happening in your
function any print statements you have
inside your JavaScript will
automatically end up as here in here but
we also will integrate with stackdriver
debugging as well so let's jump back to
the slides and see what Frank is up to
slide please thanks
so that was a basic hello world Frank
wants to actually say hello to the world
Frank has a dream of uniting hipsters
all around the globe but the world
speaks many different languages Frank
wants his chat app to let people
communicate with each other in their own
language but how can we do this let's
start by looking at his mobile app so
far Frank's app is pretty simple
there's no chat rooms there's just a
messages node each message has a unique
ID and it's a standard field for the
text you can find out how to write this
app and much more for iOS Android and
the open web on our YouTube video 0-2
app but what if we made our app a little
bit more complex what if the database
already had translations in it well now
we could see that you could very
trivially update the UI so that it only
renders the message that's in the users
preferred language of course the big
question then is how do we get the
database in this state well Google has
two great products that Frank can use
there's the firebase real-time database
that he's already using and google
translate it translate does have an API
but it's meant for server-side use so
how can Frank use this API without
including a server key inside his mobile
app well we're here at the talk today so
I'm assuming you can guess that it's
cloud functions he'll write a cloud
function that listens to the database at
messages flash ID slash message now
notice the ID here is in curly brackets
this is one of my favorite features of
our integration with the real-time
database because that's a wildcard that
means that we will match on both the
left and right side of that wildcard and
we'll capture the actual value as an
event parameter this means that a single
cloud function has the power to listen
to events that would have taken
thousands and thousands of listeners
before today once our cloud function is
started we're going to make a few
Quest's to the Google Translate API
first we're going to ask the list of
currently supported languages and then
we're going to ask for that message to
be translated in each of those languages
as we get results back we'll string them
back to the firebase real time database
so let's code it up and see it in action
we switch to the blots up please cool
so because cloud functions is a vanilla
node node client we can use node modules
you can benefit from the community of
node developers out there now our first
demo was written in vanilla JavaScript
I'm going to start writing my demos
using some more advanced features that
are part of the upcoming JavaScript 7
standard so I'm going to use typescript
to get them this will also give me
syntax completes and syntax error
checking so first let's go ahead and add
that translate API so the Google Cloud
translate library returns a function
that you should call to initialize it I
don't have to use any parameters here
because croisé functions is part of the
cloud platform and all cloud SDKs can
auto initialize inside cloud platform
this is very useful for making sure that
your app can use the same code for your
development testing and production
environments now let's write a cloud
function to listen to the database there
we go
so you'll notice we have a number of
namespaces here these are all different
services that we can use cloud functions
to respond to and a database will let us
listen to changes on references code
almost writes itself and we want to have
a write handler now you'll notice
because of type script like here we go
that we have if you can read this a
function that takes an event of Delta
snapshots and returns anything but
there's a handset it could be a
almost of anything and we'll get to that
in a second so I'm going to use an async
of handler which is part of the upcoming
JavaScript 7 features and first juice
make with my event so you'll notice that
events have many fields these are
standard fields available for every
event you handle in cloud function they
include what type of event was triggered
what resource fired that event and even
the parameters that are the actual
values of that wildcard up here the data
for each event though depends on the
kind of event you fired for a database
event it's a delta snapshot if you've
used the firebase SDK for the real time
database you're very familiar with data
snapshots a delta snapshot is everything
a data snapshot is and more so next
let's go ahead and get the set of
translations or the set of languages
available from Google Translate this
function can either take a callback a
return or promise and I'm going to
return a promise here I can either say
then and continue that way
but since I'm using typescript I can
just say oh wait now code will continue
after that's completed the Google
Translate libraries return an array of
two values the first is a simplified
value and the second is the raw values
from the rest API since I only want the
simple values I'll do this to extract
them cool now that we have our list of
languages which there are over a hundred
supported languages I want to fire that
more than 100 Network requests off at
the same time I'm going to need to
eventually keep track of that work so
let's create a temporary for each
language
I want to do something
and because it has that array I look
starts first item so now we have over
100 requests running at the same time
and I will take that value and save it
back to the database I'm going to need a
reference to the database which comes as
part of every snapshot there's a dot ref
that is where that snapshot came from
now this reference here is to this
message node if I want to make up here
I'm going to go up one level and then
back down to the language code and set
that to the translation now with an
async function I can either await the
results or just return it now all my
work is being complete I just want to
make sure that my cloud function doesn't
terminate until all the requests are
done so I can create a promise with
promise all and that will wrap up
everything that's outstanding by
returning that promise cloud functions
knows that I have background work and it
will keep the cloud function alive until
that work completes so let's try this
out in production a moment of truth so I
needed to have a write that matches
messages then some value
so this one can take a little bit like I
said there is over 200 requests in here
100 languages 100 writes back to the
firebase database but there we go so so
let's switch back to the slides and find
out what on Frank's List so Frank's
loves his users and wants to make them
feel welcome and hipster chat he hears
that bots are so hot right now and so he
decides to write his own mr. mustachio
mr. mustachios first task is going to
greet new users in the general chat room
well luckily firebase authentication
also works with cloud functions it
supports two kinds of events the
creation of a user or deletion of a user
user deletion events are great for
things like clearing out the profile
information of a user when they leave
your app but today we're going to use a
user creation event to give our BOTS in
life let's switch back to the slides
there we go
so in this demo I'm going to use the
firebase admin SDK this is the SDK that
we've written to help you build a
server-side app and of course we've been
thinking about cloud functions the
entire time to initialize the SDK we
need to call initialize out and to do
that we're going to use a feature called
functions dot config
functions not config is a snapshot of
Google runtime config from the time that
your app was deployed this is a great
way to make sure that your code stays or
in your config stay cleanly separated
this is a great way to make sure that
your apps stay testable and we've added
a special variableness config called
firebase this is automatically populated
and has everything you need to
initialize the firebase app we're going
to create a new cloud function this time
integrating with firebase off we're
going to listen to a user event
specifically the user creation event now
this time the event data is a user
record which makes sense because a user
record is what is returned when you call
create user now in order to write a
message we're going to need to push a
new value into our database here we just
have the text is the most interesting
part we're using the display name from
that user record to make sure we greet
the user the rest of this here is part
of our like how we actually inform our
UX to make sure mr. mustachio is visible
as a bot so let's see it in production
watch da fose it was too so let's go
back to slides so some time has passed
hipster chat has been growing it has so
many users in so many rooms that Frank
now needs to add a feature to let people
get others attention if they're
subscribed to a room but not currently
reading it so he's going to add at here
mentions Frank does a little bit of
research and he knows about firebase
cloud messaging
it's a cross-platform product that lets
you send notifications across iOS
Android and the open web there's only
one problem he looks at the QuickStart
sample and sees that there's a
stubbed-out message called send token to
server that's because until today you've
needed a custom server in order to be
able to programmatically send
notifications but not anymore
see Frank is clever he knows that the
firebase database has very flexible
security rules he can create private
areas in the database that are
restricted to each user and so he's
going to implement his send token the
server method so that it pushes a device
token in an area that is based off of
the user ID now he has secure storage
for all his device tokens and he can let
cloud functions do some magic now we're
going to break our push backend into two
parts rather than looking up every
device open for every user that's in the
topic when are in the room whenever you
get not here we're going to have a
subscription management piece and the
part that actually does ascending this
is the first part we're going to listen
to the change of all users in all rooms
whenever we notice that a user has
joined or left a room we're going to
subscribe or unsubscribe from an FTM
topic respectively this
dramatically simplify our push code
because now we can just scan messages if
they contain an app mention we can send
a push notification based on a topic
corresponding to the target room so
let's jump back to some code two bumps
the difficulty one more time this demo
is actually going to use raw HTTP
request so I'm going to add yet another
library so that first function was a
database function it said for every room
wild card every user wild card we're
going to listen to any write then it
could have been a user insertion or
deletion so we're going to find out
which and map it to the action that
cloud messaging supports either a batch
ad or a batch remove next we're going to
need the list of devices that are
associated with this user account so
we're going to use the admin SDK again
we're going to look up the values in
that private storage now it's possible a
user doesn't actually have any tokens
for example on iOS the user might have
disable notifications altogether so
let's check for that first if the
snapshot does not exist the user has no
tokens will log a debug message and exit
otherwise will log a different debug
message about how we're adding or
removing tokens jump to admin so since
we're making an HTTP request we're going
to need to authenticate it so this we're
going to look at that firebase config
again see part of that firebase variable
is the credential that the SDK itself is
using to authenticate that credential
serves OAuth tokens so you can get the
same cashable token that we use if
you're making any requests to another
Google service now all we have to do is
make our HTTP request we're going to
send a post to this address using the
action we decided earlier either batch
add or batch remove two Afeni kate will
add some headers and then our body will
be the topic that we want to modify and
the list of tokens we want to use so
this could be a full subscription
service as an exercise for the reader
there's some other stuff you can do for
example this method has returned value
contains an array of a list of objects
that correspond to either success or an
error if that token was expired or
invalidated but now other subscription
service in hand we can try push
notifications well write another
database event handler where we listen
to the text field of every message in
every room now if there was no @mention
which is fairly common we can just early
exit this is a smaller simpler version
of what we did before where we
console.log and then returned because
the return value of every function is
logged in the Google Cloud logging
console
so next we have the room ID from this
event that's the stable identifier but
it's not human readable we actually have
a title for our various rooms so we use
the admin SDK one more time to look up
that room title based on its ID now
we'll construct our payload we're going
to send the message to a topic based on
the room ID and a message that includes
the Friendly room name and we use the
messaging features inside the admin SDK
to send that message so let's go ahead
and see in production check - oh I
missed it there we go
sure let's push notifications and let's
go back to slides for one last scenario
so hipster chat has been growing and
Frank has his eye on quality he's hungry
for insight so he uses firebase
analytics to learn how people use his
out he's so hungry for feedback that he
added a feature where his users can fill
out a survey he's hungry you're still so
he even has an analytics event to track
when people fill out the survey and
maybe Frank is just hungry Frank was in
his coffee shop munching when he had an
idea he wants to incentivize people to
fill out the survey so he's gonna have a
giveaway his favorite treat of eating
vegan gluten free kale muffin - the next
12 people who fill out his survey
there's a number of reasons why Frank
has already marked the feedback sent
event as a conversion event for one it
lets them create a user funnel so you
can see what actions lead people to
actually fill out surveys
next he can use this to create an
audience which lets him understand
whether the people who fill out his
survey are actually representative of
his normal demographic and starting
today Frank can listen to this
conversion event with the cloud function
so let's jump back to the laptop again
so for our last function we're going to
create an analytics event or analytic
function so we're listening to the
analytic service and for the conversion
event feedback sent this is not a
built-in conversion event this is one
that Frank has created on his own and
marked as conversion whenever that event
is logged this code will run so in this
case the event data is a full analytics
event because Frank had used firebase
analytics set user ID this analytic
event has the actual firebase user ID of
the person who sent feedback this is
really important because now he can do
things like lookup profile information
or in this case give the user a gift
since Frank only has two months or
twelve muffins to give away we're going
to add people to the muffin Club in a
transaction now first he needs to check
whether or not he's already given away
all his muffins or if he's already given
this user a muffin so if he's given away
twelve muffins or he's already given
this user a muffin just exit the
transaction early no harm no foul
otherwise well log that we're going to
try to attempt to give away a muffin and
add this user to the muffin Club in our
transaction if it succeeds we'll get a
result that says committed otherwise it
will retry and we'll either try to
modify again or find out the last muffin
was given away and early exit to figure
out which is which we're just going to
have a debug statement
so once again let's see it in action
let's give feedback I'm being soft with
myself so I may not have put this one in
debug mode so it might take a little bit
for the conversion of it to come through
let's watch oh there we go
muffin Club so now I've decided to give
myself a gluten free kale muffin
so thanks I think Frank is pretty set so
let's turn it back to Brendan all right
can we switch back to the slide okay
thank you thank you so much Thomas great
kind of hungry too
all right so to recap clouds functions
for firebase is their programmatic glue
you've seen how like two sticks together
firebase and cloud products to create
your own server lists mobile backend so
the four cloud functions for firebase
firebase developers would have to setup
their own custom back-end solutions to
do many of the things that Thomas went
over today so your mobile apps would
have to connect to your own API not
allowing you to take advantage of all
the things that B firebase SDK X have to
offer as a result this would increase
complexity and time to implement the
core features that are already available
for you so with cloud functions for
firebase this is no longer the case you
get to tie together the best parts of
firebase in Google cloud to create a
completely servlet mobile backend and
you still get using firebase SDKs in
your mobile app there's no need to
manage or set up your own servers
there's no need to worry about scaling
up or down there's also no need to pay
for the resources we aren't utilizing so
we've seen a couple examples of how you
can stitch together firebase and cloud
products to easily create powerful cloud
functions you've seen how to re-engage
customers through analytics using
conversion event send notifications
using the real time database and cloud
messaging and how to automatically
translate messages into the real time
database
so firebase developers now have a
completely serverless
back-end solution companies like Sony
are building amazing things with cloud
functions for firebase and we can't wait
to see what you build you could even
start using it right now for free on the
firebase free tier to learn more you can
go to G 0 slash firebase slash functions
[Music]
you